oh [ __ ]
[Music]
killing yourself to live oh [ __ ]
it's that type of [ __ ] party tonight
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's what I'm [ __ ] talking about
right there
those are bong hits if you ain't bother
like that you are real [ __ ]
[Music]
look at that look at that right there
[ __ ] it's Wednesday night kick
out the jams brothers and sisters we got
mr. Gomez we got mr. Lisa at we got mr.
Diaz unleash on the bag of stars that's
getting consumed tonight the whole
purple bag is going down tonight we're
breaking records get Guinness on the
phone by the [ __ ] it's going down
[ __ ]
[Music]
you
oh [ __ ] mr. G is here
sup I'm telling you nobody else will
tell you open your eyes and see the
light
oh [ __ ] if you're Nadine hang up now you
bad [ __ ] we'll get this party
started tonight I'm the deep end we
ain't [ __ ] around mr. Gomez's in the
wreck from JetBlue get me see understand
me JetBlue drop them off here be [ __ ]
helicoptered here with no [ __ ]
luggage he's ready to go where's those
stars at least I am oh [ __ ]
a full bag harmonised it's not at all
I'm other Giants whatever the [ __ ]
word is it's not even open yet look at
this look at this oh you ever open up a
men's bathroom in the airport when you
go in there early you're walk-in there
you have to sleep in the men's bathroom
and you smell like a tornado of [ __ ]
and asses and different [ __ ] oh I wish
you could smell this [ __ ] bag this is
the black bag of debt this is the real
magic bag if a magician shows up on one
of these and he ain't got bees in this
[ __ ] that dude just ain't
[ __ ] real
Oh
what's up my brother so your your life
oh my god he's a good kisser
you lost a lot of weight kids I hope you
[ __ ] to focus but that I focus
on the reefer
focus on the 9-1-1 number you can have
to doubt tonight because we're going
deep I'm getting chest pains already
[ __ ] breaker you wanna flip on
Louie Gomez India [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ] she beat him up that's always a
good [ __ ] story right there cuz on a
woman's beat you up
she follows up with a little schoolgirl
I mean the understanding I don't know no
I'm not accusing nobody or not you
understand Lee come over here sit next
to uncle Joey so he can start the
process in
no [ __ ] topics tonight
[Music]
I'm sparing you tonight [ __ ]
oh my god clear - another new way don't
worry about well yeah that's the to
[Music]
start with five will progresses as for
[Music]
yeah if you eat five it's gonna take you
right to where you need to be in [ __ ]
tonight
don't behind your stars live I see
you're already playing busy there you go
this is the man of the 12 apostles
[ __ ]
look at this poor bastard him look at
screw now chill down Lois
[Music]
then I offer you down me stop [ __ ]
years we've been eating the stars stop
blowing me out
[Music]
yummy for your [ __ ] tummy understand
me
you need the stars a death in your life
we're gonna have a raffle come to the
Voodoo Lounge for a night no pictures no
cameras just straight up evil Missy
understand
guaranteed hospital visit even if you
don't want to go it's a nice evening I'm
happy you joined this tonight get that
you wanna find him mr. Goldman yes yes
oh yeah the one I hate [ __ ] Jews
look um he puts them in the back of his
mouth like a bear like he's gone into
hibernation the three you know it's good
those scars a time-released I'm saying
I'm gonna loose for the same time hey
you got my brother thank you man
[Music]
it's gonna go bad tonight yeah I'm sayin
we got a nurse I'm three minutes she
lives across the street I gave her this
small half a yard if we meet her she'll
be right over to give him out the mouth
or whatever the [ __ ] gonna go down
tonight call Guinness call Superman call
Batman whoever the [ __ ] you need to call
I already ate seven it takes you two
hours me I mean as I'm talking
I'm swallowing them whole I let them
[ __ ] I let the [ __ ] intestines break
it down for Joey to be [ __ ] around
I got one of these for you
[Music]
that's good goes to the winner of the
orange I don't worry about you know
saying it's that type of night listen
take it you up front that's it wow it's
25 an hour
what type of [ __ ] money if she works
eight hours if it takes eight hours to
bring you back then it's gonna cost me a
small fortune
[Music]
I'm keeping the start-stop talk while
your fatherly but we got a father coming
your way - who are you
just wobbly [ __ ] yeah you can't just
wallow girls been doing it for 30
[ __ ] years you think women like to
taste the [ __ ] clue no but they just
move against the back of that throat
down the hatch
they drink a [ __ ] beer right after it
and [ __ ] stomach em in this time in
kid juice tastes like milk it's complete
but absolutely where's my man talking
let with Ryan Holloway was [ __ ] Cleo
was my girl of death Michigan where's
mother [ __ ] bird the Armenian that's
the baddest [ __ ] in Glendale
growing tomatoes [ __ ] bacon bread he
don't give a [ __ ] bird selling computers
whatever you need listen if you will
have you have an Armenian friend you
[ __ ] out of luck
I'm gonna give you a pound in Maui
that's good you need it take a breather
give you intestines of breathing this is
it right here [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this
is called white fire how's that before
you was it white fire there's a pizza
with wait the [ __ ] do you think you're
dealing with then I got food poisoning I
that baked wings on Melrose I'm still
sick I had a milkshake a [ __ ] piece
of toast and [ __ ] cornflakes that's
it all day yeah
no that's it that's the voice
[Music]
are you kidding me a what
this is [ __ ] training here the
Marines do what they do we do what we do
with the church understand me you do ten
of these tonight you can swim to [ __ ]
Mongolian back
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
while the vowels got stuck we're all
right now that's straighten it out I'm
saying every once a law fart comes up
from your neck [ __ ] turns your valve
around on the inside not on the outside
anyway
what's cracking [ __ ] is the
Icehouse it's sold out tomorrow night
thank you very much and do the work out
but next Thursday June 1st I'm doing
working out with uncle Joey Thursday
night at flappers 7:30 be there be
square
we'll get the [ __ ] party started as
usual I'm just trying to get my hour
together I got about a [ __ ] year of
work and the only people that can help
me at you well it's time to see a lot of
things y'all say
[Music]
[Music]
where you gonna get this record do that
[ __ ]
[Music]
he wants it so bad it's just stupid I
[Music]
went into a 7-eleven that day something
white dude walked in with glasses it
goes
give me the whole case
he was definitely 10 minutes there you
go a little fidget
if you like Gomez will come over keep
that thing close the [ __ ] just to see
how your insides [ __ ] bark off your
[ __ ]
who said bong hit
[Music]
what's that
ah there's more to come that's just the
opening I've been training for the past
like four days many animals will just
[ __ ] yes see he's gonna keep Joey I mean
yeah bill jump a little trust me girl
you don't know how do I can't take the
chance
you're right that's my little problem I
got my policy if I die he gets 50 G's
you know this is what I just told you
right now eat the stars don't worry
about the 50 G's before you get the 15
years gotta eat the stars concept and I
got more [ __ ] life more stars and we
got us on the eye of debt hello all that
I'm worth it you know I'm saying this is
the barnacle what's his [ __ ]
name used he's like nine thousand
milligrams
yeah that's the last thing I that was
the last temptation
Oh Joey [ __ ] Diaz you eat that right
away I mean really get this party
started [ __ ] it's Wednesday
night you're gonna have this podcast for
the weekend they're taking me a
destination why are you driving I'm
happy I'm happy I got you [ __ ]
in my corner and don't forget
I think it's June 7th Thursday coolest
9th Brea
June 8th June 8th to the 10th Greg
California [ __ ] oh [ __ ] who do
piddled Merengues shoes on boy I'm
[ __ ] up on these stars and this
[ __ ] bleep this weed is good
who's up with the bucket
leave us don't eat those last three
stars Sarika [ __ ] kill the sweets we
hit this we got some good Refik tonight
we got Oreo cookies that's the hybrid
and the indica is the white fire oh gee
I had a total different source today I
got to keep well with my old source in
check they're getting cute over there I
gotta let them know I'm running
I like Orioles the double I don't like
the [ __ ] that's coated in [ __ ] that's
diabetes that's too much just give me
Oreos now I like Oreos I'll try to slip
those [ __ ] and Louise your new [ __ ]
yeah eyedrops
[ __ ] you and hydrox okay showed up with
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a very good blend of marijuana
right hold on one second hold on come
back move back keep this key phone beeps
oh allah keep hope alive there you go
now there you go
set that dragon loose oh [ __ ] Chinatown
1984 DB ma look at Jesus Christ then you
go like a [ __ ] soldier alive what
that Orioles
that's the Oreo crisis more it was nice
hey little funky things KKK I got no
look I got tropical helmet juice and I
got [ __ ] nut plasma how's that you're
a little nuts youtube.com slash Slee
slack youtube.com slash c / Joey this is
the place you ought to beat him saying
Luis Gomez uncle Joey Lisa at lease ad
has not finished
he's [ __ ] stars
last night we you 2008 1600 he always
falls short of the mark
remember the [ __ ] remember the [ __ ]
episode of the honeymooners
well he could never play the [ __ ]
trumpet that's [ __ ] ly he never wants
to play the trumpet
put the [ __ ] fidget didn't down
alright that's the last of many to get
involved in you're like a [ __ ] kid
you beat Subway sandwiches and spinning
fizzy [ __ ] things anyway we're gonna
turn this around wanna give you a little
set buddy Sabbath dissection like your
way maybe a few more Bunga sergeant the
next week we're drinking bong water I
got a new thing we could swap interest
among water
yeah [ __ ] yell with ice cubes a little
bit of Bach that will get me [ __ ] up
with this [ __ ]
you don't know what it's like do you
drink bong juice one time Cuba 66 I was
under the tunnel we had a bong it was
raining we had no weed I [ __ ] drank
the bong water I was high for 16 I'd
done it by accident on purpose who gives
a [ __ ] when you're down in the hole you
do whatever you need to do hold on one
second stay with me
oh [ __ ]
just when you thought it was safe one of
the anthems of life I know what you got
planned tonight write your goals do your
push-ups eat your carrots do what the
[ __ ] you do say your prayers
it's tomorrow's another day Lewis
[Music]
[ __ ] father
[Music]
Oh about twisted that time there's a
[ __ ] with knowing our thing in the
snappy he's gotta go star the star with
the flying jukkalan
that means a p12 you got eight more star
athlete like six more just a shaker just
to prove your points or nobody ever gets
confused nobody ever ever gets confused
if you're under 18 hang up now I didn't
tell you that early you little
[ __ ] you're gonna be sitting
there smoking or dope and then you gonna
end up like me and [ __ ] 50 y'all
[ __ ] up stop smoking dope get in the
[ __ ] 18 what about you you get 23
you're already [ __ ] you just need
help to maintain on a daily place
yond 18 stop smoking that [ __ ] it's
gonna write your [ __ ] brain
[ __ ] go do your homework
go figure out that [ __ ] bicycle you
got for Christmas the sound that we got
some kick to it jack on your right now
anyway I'm happy you joined this to see
me you know I love your [ __ ]
with all my heart don't forget you first
flappers June mother [ __ ]
eighth-graders day night Lisa axe
opening up the ceremony
he's only 20 [ __ ] stars onstage
lesson new opening act
leeches has ten minutes a week THC ah
[ __ ] space you bastard what do you get
me dog a homie missing fingertips look
at his [ __ ]
[Music]
tremendous
this song took me out of a lot of dark
[ __ ] nights you understand me just to
meander somebody hit me up on Facebook
yet and I'm saying that they've played
this out front to back and they were
blown the [ __ ] away SAP it 75 73 you had
to stand up and suck their dicks that
was just like that
here we go
minutes here we go [ __ ] where can
you run to understanding what more can
you do no more tomorrow life is [ __ ]
killing you understanding stop [ __ ]
around turn to nightmares
heaven is gonna turn the [ __ ] hell
mass of confusion nothing more to help
very paternal stars
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
not like his 28 by me
[Music]
I was the how is he twenty eight hundred
milligrams when you were stoned your
[ __ ] diapers that one [ __ ] no
so who do you think his bid was [ __ ]
uncle Joey and [ __ ] I was eating nose
medical marijuana froggies in 79 they
just didn't stick because who needs
brownies then you got a real asset I'm
saying
the leads are browning you got [ __ ]
40 out a half a cheap buzz on a pillow
[ __ ] soldier but we all make on the
space anyway you [ __ ]
youtube.com / c / Joey deters that's the
way they dope
I'll see you [ __ ] in eight
minutes stay black thank you for the
love thank you for support and tell them
all the suck your big rubbin dick